The equation y is equal
to the square root of 2x
minus 10 has a y-intercept
of 0, negative 10,
and you see that
from this equation.
The y-intercept is where do
you intersect the y-axis,
or what happens to y
when x is equal to 0.
When x is equal to 0, this
part of the expression
is equal to 0, and you're left
with y is equal to negative 10.
Rearrange the equation to
express x in terms of y.
So I've got to put
this on my scratch pad
here, so that I can work it out.
So really, we just want
to think about-- we just
want to solve for x here.
We want to rearrange to
express x in terms of y,
so let me just rewrite it.
y is equal to the square
root of 2x minus 10.
So we want to isolate the
x on the right-hand side,
so the first thing
we might want to do
is just add 10 to both sides.
Let me add 10 to both sides.
That gets rid of the 10
on the right-hand side.
And we are left with
y plus 10-- Actually
let me just keep
track of the colors
just so you can see
what I'm up to-- is
equal to the square root of 2x.
Now, let's see.
To isolate this x, let's square
both sides here, so let's
square the left-hand side.
Let's square the
right-hand side.
Of course, anything we do to one
side, we have to do the other,
otherwise the equality
will no longer be true.
And we are going to
have y plus 10 squared
is equal to-- the square
root of 2x squared
is just going to be
2x-- is equal to 2x.
And now we can divide
both sides by 2.
And we are left with x is equal
to y plus 10 squared over 2.
So let me write that out.
Let me actually type that
in into the program right
over here.
So x was equal to
y plus 10 squared
over 2, which is exactly what
I wrote down on my scratch pad.
And then they say what is
the equation's x-intercept?
So let's just remind ourselves
what's going on here.
So this curve or
this equation could
describe a curve that
looks something like this.
So that's my y-axis.
This is my x-axis.
And let's say the curve, it
might look something like this.
It might look
something like that.
So we already figured
out its y-intercept.
Its y-intercept is where
does it intersect the y-axis,
and we already figured out
that's when x is equal to 0,
y is equal to negative 10.
Now we want to figure
out its x-intercept,
so that's essentially
what x value
do we get to when
y is equal to 0?
So what x value do we get
to when y is equal to 0?
Let me just-- let me clear these
out just so this doesn't-- we
don't get distracted by
this right over here.
Well, when y is equal
to 0, x is going
to be equal to 10
squared over 2.
0 plus 10 is 10
squared, 100/2, which
is going to be equal to 50.
So we're at the point
x is 50, and y is 0.
So that's this right over here.
The x-intercept is 50.
When x is 50, we clearly
see that y is equal to 0.
So let's also put that in there.
So what is the
equation's x-intercept?
So when x is 50, y is 0.
And we can check our
answer, and we got it right.